foreign
I want to talk about my mentor
I want to talk about the day
that I got a phone call saying that he
had died
and I want to talk about the moments
later in the same phone call
that I'd heard that he'd actually taken
his own life
and I'm saying this because I want you
to listen and also think about all the
people that you love and adore and you
cannot imagine living without in your
life as you're listening to me talk
my friend My Mentor my father figure
Angus I truly loved him
my father had left the family home when
I was quite Young
and he took on the mantle to look after
me
I'd known him from a very young age he
taught me how to swim
he was my cousin's boyfriend then my
cousin's husband and he was just my
go-to guy when I was starting to date
girls and I wasn't sure what to do I'd
ring him up and I'd ask him hey what do
you think what's going on how should I
perhaps do this
when I ended up working for him years
and years later in a big Maori corporate
I would always go to him for workarounds
how can I get this deal done he always
seemed to be that guy that I could turn
to and you'd always give me the right
answer
not only me I remember walking around
the corner at work one day and there's
always someone in his office
there was always someone waiting for him
if you rang him up he was always on the
phone he'd ring you back he would always
seemed to be that guy that had people
going to him asking for help asking for
favors asking for support
he was good looking
beautiful wife my cousin three beautiful
children
white with someone like that take their
own life
why would they
makes no sense to me
and at the funeral
and talking to people after the funeral
just the frustration did you know did
you know did you know did anyone know
did you get a clue
and of course everyone's saying no I
didn't have a clue in fact he was just
like you're saying he was my go-to guy
he seemed to tick all the boxes
he seemed to just know what to say at
the right time and he seemed to be able
to work his way both personally and with
work to get life done and he was
successful
I told that story on a breakfast show
that I was on called The Grill team in
Sydney Australia I was on there for 11
years
and one morning I decided to be
vulnerable one morning I said you know
what I'm going to talk about my friend
because
we were six years into that 11-year
stint and I'd never really spoken much
about myself we spoke to Ben sport we
spoke about telling jokes
we did things like ticket giveaways and
concert giveaways and fun stuff we
wanted to get people driving to work or
listening to us having fun we didn't
want to sort of drag them down with
personal stuff or being vulnerable but
one morning 4 30 in the morning sitting
around the production table with the
producers and my co-hosts I said I'm
going to be vulnerable today
I'm going to talk about something that I
haven't spoken about before and has been
eating away at me and I want to do it
and they supported me
we've been on for a long time we're like
brothers we said you know what mate
whatever you want to do let's go for it
so 805 just after the eight o'clock news
the Hollywood hour in radio Land We
flicked on the mics and I told the story
that I just told you guys
it was hard I was getting support from
my co-host I got the words out
eventually a bit like I am today
emotional stuff certain things trigger
you
but what was truly happening behind me
was all the phone lines into the radio
station
were flashing which means people were
phoning in normally those lines would be
futuring up to be part of the show to
tell a joke to win a concert ticket to
win a movie ticket all of a sudden all
those lines were flashing
didn't quite realize why
the producer comes in and says we've got
all these people that want to thank you
for telling your story I thought that's
nice
I put myself out there it is nice to get
a little bit of love like that so we
started putting a few calls through not
only were they telling me thank you for
telling that story
more importantly it was like we'd given
them a green light we've given them
permission to talk about the stuff that
they wanted to talk about all of a
sudden in a safe place like a radio
station where they normally laugh their
way to work we'd given them a little
opportunity to talk about the stuff
that's truly important to them the stuff
that they had in their bellies the stuff
banging around in their heads
that they never thought they would get a
chance to talk about so what we did for
the next 90 minutes was just the most
beautiful radio that I've ever been
involved in
we took no traffic reports no news
reports we played no music we just had
90 minutes of people bumbling and
fumbling and getting their way through
a conversation of gravity with us in the
radio Studio
there was moments thank you
it was impressive for so many people
went you know what I'm diving in here
I'm talking about my stuff now because
he spoke about that all strangers
listening to each other on the radio all
gave each other permission to have a
chat
there was moments of true silence and
silence and radio is not a good thing
however when you have silence when you
can sort of hear the tears you can try
to just hear them Gathering
the guts and determination to say the
next word or you can basically hear this
not running out of the nose and the
tears running out of the eyes that's
when you know people are being fed ink
and that's when you know that they're
being real
so fantastic and it made me think
I wonder how many other people are
wiring alone if we just open it up on
this radio show on this morning and I
tell my story then we have 90 minutes of
people going me too me too me too I
wonder how many people are out there
feeling exactly the same way
so that day changed my life I decided to
commit myself to being more honest to
being more vulnerable but even more
importantly let's get Suicide Prevention
down to zero a huge call I know and I
said it in the Australian press and
everyone gave it to me but I don't care
I'm going to focus on making sure that
no one goes through the type of stuff
that my mate went through and how do we
do that
how do we do that that's the trick so
for the last six years I've been running
a foundation called gotcha for life I
want everyone in the world to find
someone who has got you for life
someone you can talk to warts and all
without any fear of judgment about the
truly important stuff why do we keep
celebrating with lots of people in
parties but we don't celebrate the stuff
that's a little bit harder the stuff
that's not so good
why is that the case
so that's been the focus I don't know if
you know the stats around suicide I
think we're all big enough and ugly
enough in here to know them in Australia
seven men every day two women nine
Australians that wake up this morning
won't wake up tomorrow morning
65 000 people in Australia tried to take
their own life every single year
the number one way to die if you're a
young Australian male is suicide
now according to the World Health
Organization who they tell me that in
over 1900 people that wake up this
morning won't wake up tomorrow morning
they would have taken their own life
on top of that 38 000 nearly 40 000
people will try to take their own life
today
1900 people today 38 000 will attempt
today around the world now I don't know
you guys very well but I'm sure in the
last couple of days I've got the vibe
and the love that we are all here to try
to make the world a better place
so this is not what we're going to
accept this is Line in the Sand time to
go no no more but what can you do if you
look at the world as this huge big place
it might be too big a task for you to
deal with
it might be too big in your own country
it might be too big in your own City but
what if we just started looking after
your own village
what if we just say I'm just going to
look after my own people the people that
I love and adore and I cannot imagine
living without
just imagine that
in the last few years I've been so lucky
to talk to people that have tried to
take their life but they're still with
us now those conversations are hard
I feel extremely blessed to be able to
be in those one-on-one conversations you
know what comes out of those three those
conversations three things
one they didn't want to die they tried
to take their own life but they didn't
want to die that gave me great hope
the other thing is that they were tired
and they were in pain
so if you combine tired and pain
together
you make a decision we all know
this
if you are not rested and you're in pain
you make bad calls
so if we know that they don't want to
die but they've tried to take their life
that's the hope that we need to hold on
to that means if we can get to people
before they get to an eight nine out of
ten in terms of how they feel we can
actually stop them making that permanent
decision based on a temporary situation
and that's what it's all about and
that's what I want to do with you guys
now if I possibly can
just in the small amount of time I got
left I want you to trust me let me put
my big bear hug and if you knew me well
I'd be hugging all of you if I possibly
can
I'm a hugger
covert really knocked me for six
no hugging in covert was no good
what I'd love you to do is just all of
you shut your eyes for me please
no one else can see you so please Roll
Along we're going to shut our eyes
I want you to think of someone
that you love and adore
and you cannot imagine living without
have you got
that person's face in your head
do you know what that person's name is
and have you got them locked in
now open your eyes
after three I want you to shout that
person's name out one two three
one two three
okay this is the bit
over the next two and a half days I'm
going to be haunting you I'm going to be
cuddling you I'm looking after you I'm
coming for you I'm coming for everyone
in this theater you need to do something
for me to that person that you just
shouted out I need you to send them a
text message simple as that having these
face-to-face conversations I understand
is hard but when we're building our
mental Fitness has already been
mentioned in this session we have to
start slowly so I want you to walk up to
the mental Fitness gym for me and just
open up those doors and I want you to
send a text but the words to the text
are this I love you I miss you see you
soon kiss hug kiss hug
I love you I miss you see you soon kiss
hug kiss hug hopefully you can remember
that I'll be outside if you want to get
it or ask someone I'm sure someone's
going to remember
what I want you to do is send that test
message and let's just see what
responses we get as I said I'll be
hunting you down over the next two and a
half days and I want you to run up to me
and go I've got the text here's my
response I want other people who go oh
here's that bloke and I'm looking I'm
going to walk away
I'm gonna hunt you down and the reason
I'm doing that is because I want
everyone just to have a little bit of
connection with the person that is most
important to you that person that you
thought about straight away as you shut
your eyes and went okay that's my person
it's all about connection it's all about
making sure that you look after the
people that are most important to you
work and wait it'll always be there
they'll always replace you but not these
people I would give anything to have a
cup of tea a beer go to a footy match
with my man
who took his own life I'll never be able
to do that
let's make sure that we look after our
village make sure we look after the
people that are most important to you
that is absolutely okay the worst thing
the text message gets sent out
someone goes what the
or are you drunk
or if a man sends it to a man there'll
be a phone call within 30 seconds
guaranteed
or or the worst case scenario what's
this all about well you can then say to
them well I was asked to think of
someone that I love and adore and can't
imagine living without
I thought of Youth that's a pretty cool
way to connect yourself up with the
people that are most important to you
thanks so much for listening guys I
appreciate it
foreign